the centenario stadium in montevideo
hosted the first ever world cup final in
1930 with hosts uruguay becoming the
first world champions
now uruguay is teaming up with argentina
paraguay and chile to host the 2030
world cup so that 100 years on they can
bring the tournament home
it will be the jubilee the celebration
of 100 years in the place where it all
began where they had the guts the
bravery the courage the intelligence and
the effort to start things up
the unprecedented four country bid is
called juntos 2030 which means together
2030.
all of the countries except paraguay
have previously hosted the tournament
individually
they've been working for more than three
years to get this bid off the ground
alongside south america's football
governing body comma bowl
with this joint bid marking a hundred
years we believe that it is very
important and deserving that the world
recognizes that south america has
contributed and continues to contribute
to world football
if successful the tournament could not
be more different to the one held a
century ago
in 1930 there were only 13 teams and the
whole thing was played in the same city
in just three stadiums
in 2030 there will be 48 teams with
around 15 stadiums used across the four
countries fifa expect a decision on the
hosting rights within two years but
there will be competition
romania greece bulgaria and serbia are
also lining up a four country bid
there's a joint bid from spain and
portugal and morocco is trying to become
the second african country to host
the tournament is still eight years away
though while qatar 2022 the first world
cup in the middle east is now just 110
days away and then it'll be the turn of
the us canada and mexico to host in 2026
the biggest world cup to date with 48
teams held across three countries david
stokes al jazeera